why can't the batman star robert
pattinson stand to see certain fish
dishes anymore and was he serious when
he said he wasn't working out in
lockdown keep watching for the details
of his regimen batman has been played in
a variety of ways over the years by a
wide array of actors from michael keaton
to christian bale to ben affleck then
there's the latest to don the batsuit
robert pattinson though some seem to
have done more than others before
putting on the cape and cowell there's
no doubt that every batman actor has to
put in some work to get in shape before
taking on the role the physical
standards for batman actor change from
project to project if anything it's
become more integral than ever recently
with every batman now guaranteed at
least one or two shirtless scenes
displaying bruce wayne's obsession with
remaining vigilant and mastering his
body and mind to weed out gotham's
criminal underbelly for the batman
pressure was on for the typically lean
pattenson to bulk up a bit he has
revealed that he took some fairly
drastic measures to get in shape for the
iconic role in an interview with people
magazine pattinson revealed he was on a
strict diet that helped him physically
prepare for the role in only three
months and before shirtless scenes it
got really extreme he said you just cut
down and cut down and cut down before
the couple of scenes with your shirt off
and you're counting sips of water
according to muscle and fitness cutting
back to just sips of water is a strategy
that can be used by bodybuilders and
wrestlers trying to drop weight to make
a certain weight class the 35 year old
patton said shame was his biggest
motivator in building his batman body
and he was working out before and after
work the actor has said his diet was
bland too with the sight of boiled fish
a key component of his diet causing him
discomfort today he told on-demand
entertainment i never want to see
a pizza salad again he's a white fish
yeah but just laminate yeah boiled fish
pattinson also had to undergo some
fairly intense physical training the
actor said his routine included weight
training boxing drills military sandbag
drills and three to six mile runs he
said it's all about pushing boundaries
and building up to a point where you
know you can do justice to the
physicality required the actor added
that he drew inspiration from marvel
stars like robert downey jr and chris
hemsworth pattinson's scheduled training
included cardio to start and then a
succession of exercises that sound fun
to nobody like bicycle crunches and
dumbbell side bends the physical
commitment from pattinson is all the
more impressive when you consider how
much he hated exercise before the roll
as he's admitted it would have taken a
lot to get him to do some cardio before
the batman came along he joked a few
years ago i would have run a mile from
anything with the physical edge
trainings are a lot more it's a lot more
fun when you kind of get good at it the
actor appears to think it was all worth
it and not just because the film seems
to be doing well with audiences and
critics he told people that wearing the
batsuit on set was like wearing a crown
or something adding people react to you
differently the crew reacts differently
your entire world suddenly changes
pattinson said fitting into the costume
which he claimed has an elemental power
to it ended up being an essential part
of being able to buy into the role and
accept himself in it he explained it's
funny because you read the script and
you spend loads of time trying to figure
out how can i play this character who
does these sort of audacious acts his
extensive workout routine and respect
for the batman myth may come as a
comfort to some fans as the actor has
previously commented about not working
out before the batman which had some
thinking he was not doing enough to prep
for the iconic role while the batman
production was halted due to the covet
19 pandemic pattinson said that working
out was not a high priority for him and
those working out in quarantine were
part of the problem but pattinson told
movie maker his earlier comments were
all in jest of course he was staying in
shape for the role he said you're
playing batman you have to work out i
think i was doing the interview when i
was in lockdown as well in england i was
in a lower gear of working out check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about the batman
are coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]